tres días sin agua potable este
habitante del pueblo de closed en el
sureste de francia dice que ha tenido
que aprender a prepararse para cuando
golpea la sequía
como hace mucho calor y que podría
volver a pasar puede ser útil no lo
hicimos antes pero ahora estamos
acostumbrados con la capa freática del
pueblo completamente seca las
autoridades locales se están asegurando
de que los 500 habitantes aún pueden
acceder al agua cargamos en el pueblo
vecino cargamos 30.000 litros y venimos
a vaciar el camión aquí 4 a 5 veces cada
día
es una solución improvisada no se puede
mantener en el largo plazo tenemos que
volver a las circunstancias normales
rápido ahora más de 100 pueblos en
francia no tienen acceso al agua potable
el impacto de la sequía también se
siente en el sector agrícola los
agricultores se quejan de la devastación
de sus cultivos y del forraje de su
ganado
no les queda nada para comer nada
todo está quemado no pueden comer esto
no queda nada verde y haciendo viaje
sus cultivos de girasoles también han
sufrido
están calcinados entre la falta de agua
y el calor no pudieron soportarlo una
parte dice que ha perdido el 30% de su
cosecha son de cánticos yo no banco para
no puedo vender esto la mitad de mis
ingresos se verán reducidos ante una
sociedad el gobierno francés ha creado
una unidad gubernamental de crisis para
hacer frente a lo que dice es la sequía
más severa registrada en el país